[Música]
hoy en directo a Ya lo hemos dicho vamos
a Caracas la capital venezolana porque
la petrolera estadounidense Chevron
firmó nuevos contratos con el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro luego de que
washington relajara Las sanciones contra
Venezuela para ampliar esta información
conectamos con Daniela Zambrano
corresponsal en Caracas Daniela que
alcance real tiene el acuerdo porque
previamente Chevron había dicho que no
iba a realizar inversiones En Venezuela
los contratos firmados este viernes por
el ministro de petróleo terreque laisami
y por el presidente de la empresa de
Chevron en Venezuela Javier la rosa son
para ampliar la producción
petrolera reactivar la producción de
crudo y expandir operaciones en
Venezuela sin embargo el ministro no
ofreció detalles sobre este acuerdo se
limitó a decir que en un paso importante
aunque no era suficiente Y al igual que
lo hizo el día de ayer Nicolás maduro y
instó una vez más a Estados Unidos a
levantar todas las sanciones que pesan
sobre Venezuela especialmente sobre la
industria petrolera tal y como lo decías
previo a la firma de estos contratos ya
el presidente ejecutivo de Chevron había
dicho que era improbable que Chevron
invirtiera para ampliar su producción en
Venezuela y la licencia que le otorgó el
pasado 26 de noviembre Estados Unidos
para reanudar las operaciones limita
además a que bebesa puede recibir las
ganancias por concepto de la venta de
petró por parte de Chevron sin embargo
se espera que en las próximas horas
pueda conocer un poco más sobre estos
acuerdos suscritos la tarde de este
viernes en la sede de pedevesa la
campiña recordemos que estas sanciones
pesaban sobre la industria petrolera
desde el año 2019 impuestas bajo la
administración de Donald Trump una vez
que este gobierno reconociera Juan
guaidó como presidente interino y no a
Nicolás Maduro tras unas elecciones que
consideraron no fueron legítimas Daniela
Pero entonces con todo este contexto que
usted nos está dando Quién es el
principal beneficiado con Los acuerdos
Chevron o el gobierno de Venezuela
ambos gobiernos tanto Estados Unidos
como Venezuela se benefician por este
acuerdo recordemos que Estados Unidos
estaba buscando alternativas en cuanto a
su ministro de petróleo tras la guerra
con Ucrania y el aumento de los precios
del crudo y Venezuela Era uno de sus
principales socios comerciales antes de
estas sanciones impuestas por la
administración de Donald Trump por el
parte del gobierno venezolano alivio en
las sanciones representa algo positivo
para la administración de Nicolás maduro
además de un reconocimiento
internacional y permite además que
Venezuela pueda comercializar su
petróleo a precios de Mercado recordemos
que por las sanciones con Estados Unidos
Venezuela hizo convenios con Irán y con
Asia sin embargo vendiendo un petróleo
mucho más económico para poder evadir
las sanciones y competir en el mercado